If we open up the Gif class in
the Objective-C project, we can see that
the Gif class inherits from NSObject and
conforms to the and NSCoding protocol.
We're going to need to add both
of those to our swift gif class.
Remember that in order to be visible
to Objective-C APIs, a swift class
must inherit from an NSObject and
that's true of the NSCoding protocol.
If we open up the gif.m file, we can
see that the two required methods for
the and
NSCoding protocol are implemented here.
The methods initWithCoder and
encodeWithCoder.
Naturally, we'll need to implement these
methods in the swift version as well.
You're going to rewrite the method
initWithCoder, just like you see here,
calling decode object for key for
each property to an unarchive a gif.
And you're going to rewrite the method
encodeWithCoder just like you see here.
Calling encodeObject forKey which
takes the object to be archived and
the key as parameters.
So to start off with,
here we are back in our gif.swift file.
And we're going to add NSObject and
NSCoding.
And of course the NSCoding
protocol requires two methods.
init with coder, and encodeWithCoder.
So, unarchiving is going to
look something like this and
archiving is going to
look something like this.
And I'll let you guys take it from here.